[music playing]
All right, you
guys getting ready?
Yeah.
Yes, we are.
NARRATOR: On the waters of Lake
Michigan, treasure hunter Kevin
Dykstra, his brother Al, and
researcher Jeff Zehr, or about
to dive on what may be the
remains of a wooden boxcar,
a boxcar that once contained
a reported $140 million
in stolen Confederate gold.
I think we're on it.
Everything is working
according to plan.
All the resources are great.
So I'm very excited.
NARRATOR: Unfortunately,
in the last several minutes
the waters of Lake Michigan
have become noticeably
choppier, and more dangerous.
The water out in Lake
Michigan can be very rough.
Diving off from the main deck
of the boat is just really hard.
Those waves can be treacherous.
[grunts]
NARRATOR: The rough waters
caused Kevin's body to collide
with the steel dive platform.
He appears to be
seriously injured.
[grunts]
Yeah!
Al and Jeff, out!
NARRATOR: What began as a day
of optimism and excitement
has now become one
of anxiety and fear.
He's hurt.
NARRATOR: Because Kevin
could be seriously injured,
the team cannot risk moving
him onto the deck of the boat.
They must tend to him
on the dive platform,
as Captain Dave
van Farowe rushes
the Neptune back to shore.
What's going through
my mind is panic.
It's devastating.
He's my strong brother.
He's the one that's,
you know, active.
He's always doing something.
You know, I don't want
him seriously injured.
I'm super worried.
Super worried.
Come on back here.
Hello.
He jumped off this
ladder and hit this metal
casing on the way in.
You know, I'm very worried
at this point for Kevin.
You know, I just
thank the Lord that we
were able to get him out.
But it's a scary moment
for all of us right now.
NARRATOR: Having been alerted
by Al Dykstra, Kevin's
wife, Joanna, has
rushed to the dock
at the news of Kevin's accident.
One--
Don't twist me over.
--two, three.
[screams]
NARRATOR: With Kevin back
on shore and in the hands
of medical professionals,
he and his team
must now face a
troubling question.
Could Kevin's quest to
find a fortune in stolen
Confederate gold
be over just when
he thought he was so close,
he could almost reach out
and touch it?
[siren]
Or might there be a darker and
more mysterious force at work?
A force that remains determined
to keep the gold at the bottom
of the lake, and that curses the
souls of anyone who ever dares
to bring it to the surface?